my shirt looks like a couch I love it
you think no well hey guys it's Katie
and this is my husband Chris hi and
today we've got a new challenge mhm I am
gonna try to make a gourmet dessert
shopping only at the dollar store Wow
so when you say gourmet what is that
what does that mean I feel like the best
thing to do is just show you what I mean
oh wow it's basically like artwork on a
plate yeah it is very artsy this
challenge is gonna be about how the food
tastes and also how the food looks cool
Gor maybe this will work out
org or maybe it was very bad I don't
think it's good I think it's great you
guys let us know in the comments if that
was a good fun did it even it Gor might
have I just got back from shopping and
I'm gonna say the dollar store had a ton
of stuff it had eggs it had cream cheese
butter cake pans and I now have a plan
I'm gonna make a cheese cake with a
strawberry topping and a coconut cookie
crust and then on top of that I'm gonna
have Italian meringue sugar shards candy
crushed up cookies so let's just get
right into it first thing I'm gonna do
is make the coconut cookie crust for the
bottom of our cheesecake I found these
coconut cookies that I've never tried
before so why don't we try one now
whoo they taste like toasted coconut
take about 16 of them and put them
through the food processor and grind
them up til they're nice and fine if you
have a small food processor like mine
you'll have to do this in batches add
this to a small bowl and three
tablespoons of melted butter mix that up
until it becomes a nice wet sand texture
and then I find an 8 by 8 cake pan with
cooking spray and parchment paper add
our crust to the bottom make sure you
get this nice and compacted that way it
really sticks together once it sets in
the fridge because this is gonna be a no
bake cheesecake this looks nice and even
so now we're gonna move on to making the
filling
I got a classic cheesecake mix from the
dollar store and the instructions are
really easy so all we need to do is add
the mix to a bowl and then eight ounces
of cream cheese beat this until it's
smooth and creamy now we're gonna fold
in our whipped topping all right that
looks pretty good add this to our cake
pan and then use an offset spatula to
smooth it out and make it nice and even
I'm gonna put this in the fridge and
move on to our next step okay and for
our final element of the actual
cheesecake we're gonna make a strawberry
topping now they didn't have fresh
strawberries at this dollar store I went
to but they did have strawberry jell-o
so the first thing we need to do is
combine one package with 3/4 cup boiling
water mix that together until the sugar
dissolves I'm doing the speed set method
which you then add cold water and ice
and this is just quickly bringing down
the temperature of the jello so it sets
faster stir that till the mixture
thickens up then remove any leftover ice
with a slotted spoon I'm gonna use a
ladle to gently spoon on the jello
mixture to the Cheesecake I want to make
a thin layer not a big thick one I think
I ended up using about a half of the
jello mixture make sure wherever you put
this in your fridge is very flat so that
you don't have like more jello in one
you don't want that
so the next few things we're gonna make
are gonna be the garnishes that go on
top of our cheesecake so I'm gonna make
an Italian meringue and I got some sugar
that was for coffee sugar but sugar is
sugar
so we're gonna measure out about a
quarter cup of sugar and add two
tablespoons of water just swirl out
around a bit just so that all of the
sugar meets the water they get
acquainted put that over a medium heat
and let that go until it reaches 240
degrees Fahrenheit well that heats up
we're gonna whip up one egg white at
room temperature no I came on plugs
we're plugged in we're ready to go okay
here we go
you'll beat this egg white until you get
soft peaks we've got soft peaks let's
take the temperature I'm taking your
temperature okay
we're at 240 so with your beaters on
we're going to slowly pour in the sugar
then you're going to turn the mixer up
to high
our meringue is done it's sticking to
the bowl next thing gonna make our candy
glass shards first thing we'll do is add
half a cup of sugar to a saucepan and
then a quarter cup of water so we're
gonna heat this up somewhere between 295
to 300 degrees Fahrenheit we want to get
it to the hard crack stage like hard
candy like a Jolly Rancher so you can
add food coloring to your candy to get
different colors but I'm gonna go for a
more natural look and get that golden
brown caramel color alright I think
we're there so we're just gonna pour
this on some parchment I have oh yeah
well it's still warm you're gonna tilt
your pan up and down and around to try
to spread this out we don't want thick
hard glass we want like thin delicate
shards once it's cool take something
heavy like a meat mallet or a fork or a
spoon and you can start hitting it just
get out any aggression but you need to
get out but just hit it and all these
cracks are gonna form and then it should
just peel right off and then you have
these nice little glass pieces the last
thing I'm gonna do is make a coulis
which is a French term for basically a
fruit or vegetable puree that's used as
a sauce on the plate and I feel like
every gourmet dish has it so I'm gonna
make my coulis with strawberry jam and
I'm gonna measure out two tablespoons
then add one teaspoon of water and we'll
mix that right up and then to make sure
there's no clumps in it run it through a
fine mesh strainer all right looks good
all of our elements are ready to go the
only thing left to do is assemble this
bad boy I'm going to use a white plate
for this because it's a blank canvas and
the colors are really gonna pop off of
it I'm taking my coulis and a pastry
brush and I am gonna paint the bottom of
the plate next we're gonna place a thin
slice of cheesecake in the middle okay
sorry sorry we have more cheesecake it's
fine Oh
reset take two we will just tuck in
anything that fill we'll clean up those
crumbs I'll top that with crushed wafer
cookies crushed freezer dried
strawberries I'm gonna add a couple
pieces of candy then we'll take our
candy glass and put that on top and then
pipe on some ring my meringue is not as
stiff as I want but it's still think it
looks pretty we just have to keep going
so that's what we're gonna do
last but not least I'm gonna add some
coconut pieces we'll finish this off by
adding some more on the plate and last
thing we need to do is clean it grab
here's it whoa oh my god that looks like
something from a fancy restaurant and
you're not saying that cuz you're
married no no it looks really good with
if it didn't I would say it looked like
trash yeah I really want to taste it all
right let's try it all right hmm no it's
really good whoa this score makes the
grade Wow
thank you guys for watching and let us
know in the comments if you want to see
Chris and I cook together
hey I'll cook something something crazy
goodbye you carry me off yeah
let's go here don't make me sing heavy
though make me seem light as a feather
okay
[Music]
you